foreign
[Music]
yesterday on the show I briefly
mentioned a controversy that had at the
time only recently started simmering it
was a controversy surrounding comments
made by The Humble host of this very
podcast and if you've been paying
attention at all you know that when my
comments spark controversy it's always
because I have broached a very important
subject and raised an issue of urgent
National importance such as of course
the backlash over my advocacy for the
rights of translucent mermaids the topic
this time around isn't quite that
serious but but almost
so
as I detailed yesterday during an
all-access live chat this past Friday
I was asked to give my opinion on the
subject of anime and I spent about 35
seconds on the subject in which I stated
that from my vantage point anime is
satanic now I acknowledge that I have no
argument to support that view I have no
perhaps
reason or justification for it it is
rather as the kids say A vibe anime has
a satanic Vibe that's all have I ever
seen anime
do I even know exactly what anime is
these questions aren't relevant all that
matters is that as I said in response to
a live question someone asked anime is
the work of the devil that's that's my
truth
that I live in every day
now there are those there are some who
might assume that
this comment was simply a half-assed off
the cuff joke about cartoons and that's
all now there are some who might have
observe that I've also argued for
cyclists to be imprisoned I've said that
people who leave their shopping carts in
the parking lot are morally equivalent
to serial killers and should be executed
on the spot I've called for legislation
out long small talk and elevators and
the use of emojis by males over the age
of 18. I even spent three months on this
show attacking my own employer over his
refusal to give me a giant stuffed
walrus
so you might assume that my theories
about anime's satanic Origins
should be taken in the same Spirit as
all those other sorts of comments
and you're right because I'm totally
serious about all of it
it's good then that social media took it
with the seriousness that it was
intended I was one of the top trending
subjects on Twitter Nationwide yesterday
again this time due to my controversial
stance on anime a great many accounts
with anime avatars expressed their hurt
and anger over my opinion leading me to
believe that maybe I was wrong about
anime causing demonic possession maybe
it actually just causes you to become an
extremely whiny dork that's another
theory meanwhile the news media jumped
into action my randomly muttered hot
take about anime made it into the
headlines of several major news outlets
Yahoo news reports daily wire troll Matt
Walsh denounces anime as satanic though
he doesn't know why
denounces I denounced it
mediaite says Matt Walsh declares anime
satanic but admits he's not sure why
the independent says Matt Walsh says he
thinks all anime is satanic and adults
shouldn't be watching cartoons
Newsweek takes a slightly different
angle they say daily wire host who
called anime satanic blasted by real
satanists
oh well if real satanists are angry
about it then
I guess I'm more right than I ever
realized
so I can now with more confidence than
ever
say that that I stand by my comments
obviously well if you feel like you need
more respect in your life than
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of Lord or lady and
gain that respect and you so richly
deserve all you need is a one square
foot plot of land in Scotland
established titles is a Project based on
a historic Scottish customer landowners
are referred to as lairds or Lords and
Ladies in English in your title pack
you'll be bestowed with at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland plus
an official certificate with a Crest
which I now hold in my hands or
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are also
couple packs that come with an adjoining
plot of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or ladies your credit card statements or
plane tickets
even your dating profiles most
importantly and get this established
titles told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine
that is quite an honor so depending on
how many of you want to become a lawyer
lady we can build our own kingdom
together established titles is actually
running a massive sale right now plus if
you use the code Walsh you get an
additional 10 off so go to establish
titles.com Walsh to get your gifts now
and help support the channel
um anime is satanic
and it leads to demonic possession in
upwards of 87 percent of cases studies
show
recent reports suggest that hat listen
to this listen to this
half of all Pokemon fans will become
Mass murderers
the other half will also become Mass
murderers
if any of my critics had ever studied
history they would know that Adolf
Hitler Genghis Khan Caligula all were
anime fans or would have been if it
existed in fact and this statistic is
the most shocking of all
I want you to listen closely to this
nearly 100 percent of all violent
criminals in the country
have seen Dragon Ball Z
or have heard of it
or know someone who has seen or heard of
it
the numbers speak for themselves
though In fairness there is perhaps no
reason to single out Japanese animation
in this way sure it's especially weird
and unsettling but it's from Japan after
all so what do you expect really though
every cartoon is satanic that's the only
clarification all that I'll offer here
every cartoonist look at PAW Patrol for
example
talking dogs with dead lifeless eyes who
engage in all manner of sorcery
the whole town of Adventure Bay cowers
in fear under the tyrannical regime of
these beasts even the mayor who's really
a figurehead obeys their every whim
there are no checks and balances in this
system
the PAW Patrol are given free reign to
be judged jury and potentially
executioners
now when you consider that scripture
often uses wolves to symbolize the
forces of evil you begin to see in the
PAW Patrol sort of perverse satanic
fable
and this is still one of the Tamer shows
what about Coco melon a bizarre deranged
plotless hypnotic spectacle which places
toddlers into an insensible trance-like
state where they mutter incantations
summoning dark Forces that they don't
understand
these are yet more cartoon related
opinions that I am seriously stating in
which I hope will be taken as seriously
as I mean them
of course hypothetically
as a thought experiment if you were to
pretend for a moment that with my
Infamous anime commentary I was actually
just making a random spur of the moment
joke about a subject that I really don't
care about at all and that Media Matters
is creating a controversy over something
that I forgot I even said 45 seconds
after I said it
then in this alternate universe one
might make the following observation
it is sad that we live in a culture
where you can't speak off the cuff or
offer an opinion even ironically or
ingest or only half seriously without it
being clipped and isolated and turned
without your consent into your die-hard
Mantra or fundamental belief system I
had people yesterday demanding to know
why I've chosen to die on this hill why
am I ranting about an anime why do I
care so much about what other people
choose to watch well am I dying on a
hill by making a flippant hyper
hyperbolic remark on a subject that
someone else asked me about
is literally everything you say a hill
you're dying on
Are you seriously pretending that you
never exaggerate or engage in hyperbole
or say something outrageous for comedic
effect are you pretending that you've
never articulated an edgy or weird
opinion maybe seriously maybe as a joke
maybe as some mixture of the two are you
pretending that you don't understand
these methods of human communication
that are utterly commonplace in a
feature of nearly every conversation
you've ever had in your life
yes you are pretending that you are
pretending so that you can score
whatever point you think you're scoring
here and the effect over time is that
authentic conversation is stifled and
people feel as though they have to
constantly speak like they're reading
from a press release written by a
corporate PR firm the color and flavor
of human conversation the stuff that
makes it fun and interesting just kind
of Fades away
these are all things that you might say
if you believe that I was not being
totally serious when I declared all
animation made in Japan satanic
but again I was serious
I'm serious about everything
if I was joking I would laugh
deadpan humor has never been my thing as
you well know
and that is why
in the end
with all that said anime is still
canceled
and cast back down into the fiery hell
Flames from whence it came
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]